Now let's look at this whole additional
concept of finding panoramas.
One of the restrictions of the way
we've talked about panoramas so
far has been that you have to
take a sequence of pictures,
panning left to right and
in different formats.
>> Well, that sound rather restrictive.
So, what we want to be able to do is
kind of find these panoramas from
a collection of pictures.
This actually also has been studied,
basic idea is that we want to be able to
find similar you know, find images from,
and run RANSAC and find the most
similar types of these patches, and
say okay, these two images
are the most closest to each other.
Let's actually build
a panorama on this one.
Similarly, find another region that
might have you know, similarities and
use that, and keep going that way, and
third one, of course, would be again,
similar ones, and in essence,
what we do is we will use RANSAC and
other types of matching techniques,
we can find images that are next to each
other and
we use that to form a panorama.
So we don't really have to worry
about taking pictures in a sequence.
This was a method proposed by at Brown
and Lowe and actually it's one of
the papers I would like you to look at
on your own and use that as a method of
trying to understand how we can actually
do this kind of stuff with taking
pictures that are not actually just in
sequence but can be taken in any order.